we do situational comedy you get you
you're really you're you're a guest in
people's home every week they allow you
to come in and uh you know it's
important that we have so many you know
uh great television shows nowadays with
all the streamers and everything yeah
you know you want to you want to get a
little bit of Slice of Life out of these
situations you were right I have an
understanding of what people go through
we play a regular family in a Suburban
part of Los Angeles you know uh that has
this kind of gentrification issue and
and I know that people deal with that
all the time and not only that is you
know we we dealt with uh you know who
they call geriatric pregnancy like late
life practice of course this season we
know with all the road Wade stuff was
coming up so a lot of things that we try
to just try to talk about in a
situational comedy kind of way but you
know let's talk about what's going on in
the world